Carrie Lake spoke at least twice at CPAC
based on the number of outfit changes
she said a lot of extremely bizarre
things I don't know how much longer
Kerry lake has to be paid attention to
now if she does run for Senate in
Arizona in 2024
she will get another round of attention
but here is Kerry Lake crowning Stephen
Bannon the fox the indicted and
convicted uh Breitbart propaganda
Steve Bannon she says he's like George
Washington Steve
crowd
yeah where's that
where's that Washington
in what way really really weird and as
we as you know Kerry lake is one of the
sickest people in politics right now at
another moment during one of her two
CPAC speeches she talked about how God
told her all about the things she's
doing and it really sounds like the type
of thing that should be explored
um in therapy quite frankly God placed
us at this moment for a reason I talked
about my moment with God where he told
me you're going to do something special
someday someday and I don't know what it
is it may still be to come who knows but
I know that putting me in the center of
all of this with my fighting spirit I
believe that God is truly in control at
this moment and we win I believe we win
at the end of the day
he placed mild Applause for that and
part of it is the her she didn't have
big crowds just here for a reason right
doesn't make accidents he doesn't he
doesn't
accidentally Place us where we are we
are here for a reason just the same as
our founding fathers at that pivotal
moment where place where they were in
1776. part of Year Sam Adams Patrick
Henry and what we're facing right now is
no different yep in the same way that
God placed Paul Revere in a position to
be one of the founders he placed Carrie
Lake in a position to I guess lose the
governorship of Arizona and then lastly
and again this seems to be a different
Carrie Lake speech because she's wearing
different clothes she is now telling the
story that someone tried to bribe her
out of politics tell me if you believe
this story nothing happened to me this
week before I left for CPAC and it shows
are to stop me and to silence you
I decided to share this it's a little
bit controversial but I'm going to put
this out
somebody showed up at my door whoa this
week they called me before and said I
gotta talk to you in person this can't
be done over the phone she's always kind
of like uh oh what's that going to be
about
they came to my door and they tried to
bribe me out of getting out of politics
and they said sir
this really happened now by the way did
you listen to the exact word she used
listen to that they called me before and
said I gotta talk to you in person this
can't be done over the phone she's
always kind of like uh oh what's that
going to be about
they came to my door and they tried to
bribe me out of getting out of politics
now that's not what she means she's
her control command of the English
language is so poor she said they tried
to bribe me bribe me out of getting out
of politics in other words they wanted
to pay her to stay in politics but
that's not what she actually means it's
another one of these accidental double
negatives and you'd think for someone
who spent so much time talking on TV she
would be able to better explain herself
but anyway she doesn't mean bribe me out
of getting out of politics she means
they tried to bribe me out of politics
okay
it's really happened
who runs for office and they're afraid
of me
they tried to bribe me with a job title
with a huge salary a position on a board
this is how they do it
and I said are you kidding me
I walked away from a big job and a big
salary I'm not motivated by that stuff
guys all right anyway so she'll
hopefully keep losing elections but
Carrie Lake out of out of this world do
you believe that story that she just
told
I have a real hard time believing it all
of these clips will be on our YouTube
channel youtube.com the davidpackman
show make sure you are subscribed folks
hit that subscribe button on the YouTube
channel and remember you can find these
clips in Spanish at davidpackman.com
Spanish
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpicks.com today save 10 with
the code pacman10 at checkout out just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below